with no parts markup and only a 75 build
fee redux gaming pcs are the obvious
choice for gamers who demand the best
without paying extra with as little as a
few clicks you'll get a pc optimized for
you and the games you play at a price
that fits your budget and all redux pcs
are backed by two year warranty to see
all that redux has to offer and to start
configuring your next pc head to the
link in the description below
alright so obviously i am late to this
video if you haven't
watch i am still recovering from covid
and i wasn't going to come back to work
and go right into uh the amount of
testing that it takes to you know bring
you guys a graphics card review on day
one in fact i'm still taking it slow and
i'm gonna give you more of an opinion
piece about the 3060 because by the time
this video has come out you guys will
have probably already seen 5 10 15 who
knows how many videos about everyone
regurgitating the same specs and the
same marketing spiel that nvidia wants
you to repeat so i'm going to give you
an opinion piece about this card instead
which admittedly might be a little bit
more valuable than talking about the
specs so first things first the rtx 3060
not to be confused with the 3060 ti has
the most ram available out of any 30
series card
short of the 90. so there's already a
weird thing happening there um as
everyone already knows that is nothing
more than a bunch of marketing circle
jerk so everyone can start competing
over the low end cards and who has the
most ram because we all know amd comes
out with 16 gigabytes on pretty much all
of their cards again a big marketing
circle jerk on amd's side because none
of that ram matters on the lower end
cards because they can't push the
resolutions at the frame rates they
would need to push them to have that
size frame buffer even matter the rtx
3060 may have 12 gigabytes of vram which
is more than 360 ti however has a
narrower bus which means it's still not
going to be able to benefit 12 gigs of
vram not even 1440p
sure maybe a few titles might push it up
to 10 or 11 gigabytes but the 12
gigabytes honestly is nothing more than
a marketing pitch to try and make you
think you're getting more for your money
which you're not second of all the 3060
i'm gonna go ahead and give him video a
little bit of a support in this area in
that when it was announced
amd also announced their new
6000 series card or whatever that's
coming that's going to also be a
probably a 6700 or something like that
um it's going to have probably 16
gigabytes of vram and a lot of people
are just like stunning all over both
nvidia and amd saying why the hell are
you bringing out new cards when you know
they're not going to be available anyway
well if you understand the manufacturing
process then you would know that these
lower tiered cards that shared the exact
same gpu die number whether it be t104
or tu102 or tu-106
the lower end cards are made from the
leftovers of the higher end cards of the
the wafers and the silicon that didn't
meet the cut to be a higher tiered skew
so what they do is they shave them down
even more they make these lower end
cards so do i fault them for making it
and bringing it out during a world
pandemic right now which has also led to
the shorted the biggest shortage of
silicon that we've ever seen in our
history no because they already have it
so they might as well at least divvy
that up amongst their aibs to come out
with these aftermarket cards which is
also probably why you're not seeing a
founder's edition card because of the
fact that all of the silicon went to the
aibs so that's why i'm not faulting
either of these brands for actually
bringing out new gpus that you
admittedly are not going to be able to
buy speaking of buying them let's go
ahead and talk about what the experience
was of watching
the 9 a.m roll over happen when things
went live big surprise just like
everyone else best buy went right from
coming soon to out of stock nvidia's own
website when you say check availability
just links you back to newegg which then
just has nothing but the newegg shuffle
which is where your name gets tossed in
a hat and you have to hope your name
gets picked to be able to buy a card
rather than actually having a first come
first serve service no the guy who signs
up last could end up beating the guy who
signed up first because of the shuffle
which of all the different ways you
could go about purchasing a graphics
card i think it's the stupidest one out
there unfortunately i also looked at
micro center which is a in-store
purchase only which is where you're
going to have the best bet to actually
buy one
granny to live close enough to one to go
wait in line two or three hours
ahead of the store opening in the
morning to hope that you end up getting
one of those cards before they're sold
out in terms of stock check at nine
o'clock in the morning at tustin the
tustin california store
many of the sku said 20 plus available
some said 10 some said five however that
store doesn't open until 10 am which
hasn't happened yet so i don't know how
fast that number is going to go down
however if we look at the pricing it's a
little bit disturbing
because it's more obvious now than ever
that the aibs themselves well i'm mostly
all the aibs and we do have an evga card
here that was sent to us by nvidia not
evga this is the only card that seems to
be coming in anywhere near msrp this one
is the evga xc
so this is 389 msrp showing at both
micro center and i think best buy had
one in newegg or whatever um it was the
only one under 400 bucks the other ones
are showing in the 500
and the
629 dollar for the pny 3060. absolutely
ridiculous now here's the problem if you
go to nvidia's website and you check
availability on the sku for 30 60s
rather than nvidia selling them through
their own store they're just linking
directly back to newegg i wonder how
much newegg paid for that so that
according to nvidia the only place to
buy it is new egg but that's a whole
nother problem to talk about newegg then
shows
those cards available under the newegg
shuffle at the msrp 329 for all of those
skus however if you then go to micro
center best buy at the other rick rick
and rick and morty stores
brick and mortar stores
you'll find that those same
manufacturers and the same cards with
slightly tiered differences like you've
got the ventus card right you get the
twin frozen card or whatever they're
calling it these days from like msi
you'll find that they're 329 when linked
through nvidia but then over 500
when directly going to the brick and
mortar stores so the question is now
who's actually scalping them is it the
aib
or is it the store
i think there's probably a little bit of
guilt on both parties you probably have
the aibs i'm holding up the evga card
unfairly because again this is the only
card that seems to be coming in anywhere
near its msrp when you've got the stores
raising or the aibs raising the msrp of
their own card and then the store
raising it again because again
capitalism free market the thing is
worth whatever anyone's going to pay for
it in a shortage people will pay stupid
amounts for stupid products
that is what it is so yeah if i sound a
little salty about that i'm sharing in
your guys distaste i'm sharing your guys
frustration
when it comes to buying these cards and
i'm sorry i don't actually give a flying
freak about the 30 60. i very rarely
care about the 30 60 cards but knowing
the fact that the the 60 series models
now are deep in the 300 msrp price range
and the realistic retail price being
almost 600
make these the worst buy of the year but
i still have to show you guys how some
of the performances what i'm going to do
is i'm going to just do some spot check
of the 3060
versus the 3060 ti because i want to see
how close it gets to it and i'm going to
compare it to the 2016 i mean i might in
a couple of things we have some numbers
for the 2060.
just to show what that uh price jump to
performance jump is
i think we're going to find that the
lowest effort card
is just a terrible value right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so i know i probably seem like
i'm being a little bit hard on the 30
60. i mean there's no surprise it was
coming there's been a 60 series card for
as long as the nvidia cards have
basically been around well ever since i
ditched the four digit moniker in terms
of pricing and value we have to speak in
these in these ridiculous hypotheticals
because we know the msrp is not what the
cards are going to cost again
the evga xc black is basically their
their closest to msrp card and
everywhere i've looked so far i found
this for 389 nvidia basically swore and
promised that there would be cards
available at 329 but we already talked
about the problem with that when they
link back to newegg all of the uh the
cards that had the whole 329 price tag
with them
have the stupid little randomized
purchasing option and then one of them i
think was the ventus was sold out and
then newegg had other cards available at
exorbitant prices so it's kind of like
they
basically scratched in videos back by
agreeing to that because of course
nvidia is going to do what it can on its
store which is just a redirect
to control the pricing but there's so
many other players in this in terms of
the stores um the aib setting their own
ridiculous pricing that at 329 this
would have been a really good card
especially when you compare it to the
charts that we just showed
versus the 2060 not the 2060 super but
the 2060. i don't know if there's gonna
be a 3060 super i doubt it in fact one
of the reasons why we probably only uh
saw 3080s 3090s and 3070s and only a 360
ti and not ti's of the other models is
the best analogy that phil kind of put
it as is they don't have the inventory
to do it themselves he said nvidia
basically can print their own money the
problem is they've run out of paper and
i think that makes the most sense here
at 329 dollars i think it would have
been a fantastic buy the 12 gigabytes of
vram is a is a marketing gimmick it is
not necessary on this card 12 gigabytes
of vram with the memory bus that's
available on the 3080 would have made
more sense why they limited the 30 80 to
11 gigs is still beyond me and then the
30 90 jumping all the way to 24 gigs we
know is for workstation loads but
remember they also didn't classify that
as a true workstation card because they
still shaved a lot of the floating point
uh performance out of it and the titan
rtx is still a better card for various
workflows uh depending on you know they
continue to shave down their workstation
cards right and the 3090 is just really
this true in between card
making it a really ridiculously
overpriced over v-rammed gaming card and
not a good enough true workstation card
those that are doing like blender and
stuff yeah you're not going to be doing
much mining on this card
those that are in the know on the mining
when they talked about the specs were
basically saying this card would be a
terrible mining card it would not really
pay for itself especially at the
inflated pricing
30 60 pricing now being that of you know
what's funny
if you go and look at the prices of some
of these these these brick and mortar
stores the price of the 360 is actually
higher than that of the 360 ti because
you can't buy a 360 ti but because you
can buy a 360 or at least could when we
started the video and can't now by the
time we got to this point because all
the micro center options that i showed
here where we had in stock the second
the store opened
it's basically
out of out of stock now best buy also
out of stock nvidia's link's out of
stock newegg out of stock where it was
in stock for those few moments the price
was already artificially inflated to a
ridiculous price so
what i'm basically trying to say here is
i don't really care i'm so burnt out on
graphics cards just like you guys i've
justified so many times saying we review
the variance of the cards that way when
you guys can find one you can at least
say hey i know which one i want to buy
and if it's worth it for the price that
you're able to find it for we only have
one 360 to look at i doubt we're going
to get any more to take a look at
especially after this video
and
you know at the end of the day with the
scalping and when i say scalping i'm
referring to the aibs themselves because
so many of them truly are being their
own scalpers and we're caught at it and
then they come up with some stupid story
trying to defend themselves that your
boldface lies
to the point to where if you can find
one in stock you got to start asking
yourself now is the 3060 worth what you
would have paid for a 1080 ti when it
first launched pascal being quite
honestly one of the best periods for
nvidia as far as i'm concerned
ampier when we first saw it come out was
supposed to be this saving grace for pc
gamers more performance
per dollar than we've ever seen i think
until pascal actually and then it they
beat pascal in that performance per
dollar which turned out to just come be
a complete farce i think that's a word
because of the fact that it's just
simply not available
the availability draws or it drills all
the way down to just the fact that with
everything being computerized these days
and even the autumn did you know a lot
of automotive manufacturing here in the
united states and in detroit where we
technically are still manufacturing some
cars has halted for many brands because
of the fact that the ecu's that are
needed to complete the assembly of these
vehicles are also unavailable because
they're all made in these same factories
that are creating these socs and the
wafers and the chips and
the the raw materials that are needed to
build the parts for the cars
are also unavailable so not just gamers
and it's one of those things where right
now all manufacturing is being
prioritized to the automotive market so
that you know it's considered much more
essential than gaming computers
it's gotten to the point to where
obviously when you drill down to a lot
of these sub markets that's why the
availability is as poor as it is
so just like you guys i'm fatigued i'm
i'm really tired of talking about stuff
that i know you can't go out and buy as
a product reviewer i still feel it's my
job to talk about it and show you the
performance where we can and give you
some information to arm yourself with
once you finally can go and buy it to
make an informed decision
but i'm not going to fill your inbox
with a bunch of 30-60 content it's it's
stupid to do that there's a lot of
videos out there that you can get
information from
and i recommend you go and watch those
videos if you're interested in learning
more about the card and less about my
opinion about why i'm just not
feeling it alright guys thanks for
watching sound off with your uh comments
about the 3060 and this whole launch
fiasco and right now my gpu giveaway is
probably your best chance at actually
getting a graphics card right now and
i'll tell you about that right here and
by the way i know you guys are probably
sick about seeing this at the end of our
videos it's only a few days left so if
you've been holding off now's the time
to sign up
hey you before you click off this video
you may or may not be aware i'm actually
doing a worldwide graphics card giveaway
where one winner will get to choose
either a 6800 xt merc 319 card from xfx
or a 2080 ti msi gaming x trio from
team nvidia so if you're sitting there
right now going i didn't know about this
how do i enter follow the description
down below you guys will find a link to
the giveaway video that will give you
all the details
don't wait because it really sucks to
find out about these after they're over